[Music]
we all like to go to the movies and
that's no secret
even so more and more people have been
enjoying their favorite films and series
from their couch at home
in the process there are tons of movie
scenes that we would like to pause or
re-watch a second time
so it's hardly surprising that there are
a couple of scenes with hilarious
mistakes
or surprises that have been more watched
than others
today we proudly present a selection of
film scenes which have been paused or
rewound particularly
often and hence went down in history
let's not waste any time and get started
the first movie scene dates back to 1977
and appeared in star wars a new hope
some of you may already know this
scene but some of you may not it's a
scene that was never planned
as such and that has become legendary
for this very reason
a group of stormtroopers rush into the
hideout of c3po
and r2d2 but the steel reinforced door
isn't fully open and so the mishap
occurred
one of the stormtroopers bumps his head
while charging against the door
so he has to put back on his helmet did
that really just happen
must many fans have asked themselves
well pausing and replaying that moment
this awkward scene became so well known
that george lucas decided to add a sound
effect in the 2004 version
to draw even more attention to it but
there's more to it than that he even
went
so far as to purposely incorporate a new
headbutt into the prequel
star wars attack of the clones
the next scene is from the superman
movie man of steel
in which clark kent's alias superman is
personified
by henry cavill when he flies towards
the transforming machine in an
energy beam the face of christopher
reeve who passed away in 2004 and was
known for his superman role in previous
movies
can be perceived for a few seconds after
a while
however this fan theory turned out to be
unintentional
as zack snyder made clear in fact there
was no face
implemented using cgi it just looks like
it due to the similarity of the two
actors faces
too bad actually we would definitely
have liked this as an easter egg
in his early 20s the stockbroker jordan
belford played by leonardo dicaprio
founded his own company which quickly
became a big hit
he becomes a multi-millionaire and
enjoys his excessive life of
luxury to the fullest margot robbie who
plays the sexy woman
at leonardo dicaprio's side has a scene
in the film in which she arouses the
stock broker with her sex appeal by
splaying her legs
to her surprise this moment was
broadcast live by a security camera
which her husband had hidden in the
teddy bear in the children's room
thus not only did her spouse get deep
insights
but sadly also the security staff
although an exceedingly large number of
viewers
can't help themselves from pausing here
the curious will be disappointed as the
perceptives and
cuts are brilliantly set many of you may
not or
partially have noticed it but tyler
durden played by brad pitt
appears several times in the movie fight
club even before his character was
actually introduced he makes his first
appearance a few milliseconds in the
hospital corridor here is the moment in
slow motion
next he appears in the encounter group
where he's standing
provokingly and arrogantly in the middle
of the room
or as the narrator is looking for the
woman in the dark back alley
tyler lights up a cigarette in a relaxed
manner
but that's not all in the office he
already sneaks into the scene
too well our main protagonist is
boringly making copies at the copy
machine
but see for yourself if you thought that
this must be everything
you're mistaken because already in the
hotel
tyler appears on a tv commercial here
on the right side last but not least
when tyler is
beaten by lou you can see the narrator
in pain
upon closer examination the already 39
year old movie
raiders of the lost ark from 1981 has
also
a special moment on hand for us while
harrison
ford threatens his enemies with a
bazooka a fly
makes itself comfortable on the lips of
his rival
played by paul freeman and then it makes
its way
straight into his mouth this high
protein meal shall not be granted to the
actor because just as the little fly
reaches its goal
a few frames which must not have made it
to the final cut
go missing leaving us the question
whether the little guest survived
it is certain however that everyone
discovered the fly
press pause here too in the movie
there's something about mary
we see ben stiller on the day of his
first encounter with the parents of mary
played by cameron diaz as he entraps his
private parts in the zipper
ouch when mary's stepfather tries to
help her date
we as the viewers could flush with shame
since the reactions of the actor lets
our imagination run free
eventually the scene of the accident is
presented to the audience for a couple
of seconds
many must have wondered what exactly he
got stuck in
and others must have wished they'd never
seen this
just in case we'll spare you this sight
by censoring it
in january 1999 disney had to withdraw
over 3 million video cassette tapes of
the animated cartoon
the rescuers due to a picture of a naked
woman that could be seen for
two single frames this moment is hard
if not nearly impossible to catch sight
of at normal running speed
however one person managed to pause at
the right moment
and so when it became apparent the scene
for the new version was immediately
substituted in retrospect
it turned out that it was a shot from a
playboy magazine
perhaps i should remind you we are still
talking about a disney movie
in the 2014 movie troy we noticed a
particularly small
but funny detail in the fight scene in
which paris is running
back to secure the sword one of the
shield-bearing opponents falls quite
brutally to the ground
and loses his shield in the process but
see for yourself
did you spot it here again look to the
left of paris
above the lying helmet now we are going
to talk about the most
paused scene in film history hence why
it should not
be missing from our summary in basic
instinct the actress
sharon stone uses her feminine charms
during an interrogation to manipulate
police officers
including michael douglas in order to do
this she crosses her legs so that
deep insights are bestowed upon us
originally
the scene wasn't in the script like that
at all however during a meal with sharon
when the director talked about an
acquaintance who had demonstratively
gave a glimpse under her skirt
the actress was ready to incorporate
this into the film
she did know that the scene was actually
shot without panties
but she assumed that you wouldn't really
be able to see anything in the final
version
as soon as sharon stone saw the movie
for the first time with an audience
she was so shattered that she slapped
the director in the face
now this is your chance which movie
scene made you press
pause if you like this format please do
not hesitate to leave us a like
and we will work on further videos for
you guys
[Music]